in the early days when you didn't have
when you didn't have adult
responsibilities of leading teams and
all that kind of stuff and you can focus
on just
being a programmer what did the
productive day in the life of john
carmack look like how many hours is the
keyboard how much sleep what was the
source of calories that fueled the brain
uh what was it like what time did you
wake up
so i was able to be remarkably
consistent about what was good working
conditions for me for a very long time
um
i was never one of the programmers that
i that would do all-nighters going
through work for 20 hours straight it's
like my brain generally starts turning
to mush after 12 hours or so
i am
but the hard work is really important
and i would work for for decades i would
work 60 hours a week i would work a 10
hour day 6 days a week and try to be
productive at that now my schedule
shifted around a fair amount when i was
young without any kids i am any other
responsibilities i was on one of those
cycling schedules where i'd kind of get
in an hour later each day and roll
around through the entire time and
i'd wind up kind of pulling in at two or
three in the afternoon sometimes and
then working again past you know
midnight or two in the morning
and
that was i'm
when it was just me trying to make
things happen i am and i was usually
isolated off in my office people
generally didn't bother me much at it
and i could get a lot of programming
work done that way
i did settle into a more normal schedule
when i was taking kids to school and
things like that so kids were the
forcing function that got you to wake up
and
at the same time it's not clear to me
that there was a much of a difference in
the productivity with i with that where
i kind of feel if i just get up when i
feel like it it's usually a little later
each day but
i just recently made the focusing
decision to try to push my schedule back
a little bit earlier to getting up at
eight in the morning and trying to to
shift things around like i'm
i'm often doing experiments with myself
about what should i be doing to to be
more productive and one of the things
that i did realize was happening in
recent months where i would i would go
for
a walk or a run i cover like four miles
a day and i would usually do that just
as the sun's going down at here in texas
now and it's still really damn hot but
i'd go out at 8 30 or something and
cover the time there and then the
showering and it was putting a hole in
my day where i would have still a couple
hours after that and sometimes my best
hours were at night when nobody else is
around nobody's bothering me but that
hole in the day was a problem so just a
couple weeks ago i made the pit the
change to go ahead and say all right i'm
going to get up a little earlier i'm
going to do a walk or get out there
first so i can have more uninterrupted
time so i'm still playing with factors
like this as i kind of optimize my
my work efforts but it's always been
you know it's it was 60 hours a week for
a very long time to some degree i had a
little thing in the back of my head
where i was almost jealous of some of
the programmers that would do these
marathon sessions and and i had like
dave taylor one of the guys that he had
he would be one of those people that
would fall asleep under his desk
sometimes and all the the kind of
classic hacker tropes about things and a
part of me was like i was a little
bothered that that wasn't me that i i
wouldn't go program
20 hours straight because i'm just i'm
falling apart and not being very
effective after 12 hours i mean yeah 12
hour programming that's fine when you're
doing that but
it never you're not doing smart work
much after at least i'm not but there's
a range of people i mean that's
something that a lot of people don't
really get in their gut where there are
people that work on four hours of sleep
and are smart and can continue to do
good work but then there's a lot of
people that just fall apart so i do tell
people that i always try to get eight
hours of sleep it's not this you know
push yourself harder get up earlier i
just do worse work where
uh you know there's you can work 100
hours a week and still get eight hours
of sleep if you just kind of prioritize
things correctly but i do believe in
working hard working a lot i
there was a comment that uh game dev
made that
that i know there's a backlash against
really hard work in a lot of cases and i
get into online arguments about this all
the time but he was basically saying
yeah 40 hours a week that's kind of a
part-time job and
if you are really in it you're doing
what you think is important what you're
passionate about
working more gets more done and i it's
just really not
possible to argue with that if you've
been around the people that that work
with that level of intensity and just
say it's like no they should just stop
and we had
i kind of came back around to that a
couple years ago where i was using the
fictional example of
all right some people say they'll say
with a straight face they think no you
you are less productive if you work more
than 40 hours a week and they're
generally misinterpreting things where
your your marginal productivity for an
hour after eight hours is less than in
one of your peak hours but you're not
literally getting less done there's a
point where you start breaking things
and getting worse
worse behavior and everything out of it
where you're literally going backwards
but it's not at eight or 10 or 12 hours
and the fictional example i would use
was imagine there's an asteroid coming
to impact you know to crash into earth
destroy all of human life i do you want
elon musk or the people working at
spacex that are building the interceptor
that's going to uh to deflect the
asteroid do you want them to clock out
at five because damn it they're just
gonna go do worse work if they work
another couple hours and you know it
seems absurd and that's a hypothetical
though and everyone can dismiss that but
then when coronavirus was hitting and
you have all of these medical personnel
that are clearly pushing themselves
really really hard and i'd say it's like
okay do you want all of these scientists
working on treatments and vaccines and
caring for all of these people are they
really screwing everything up by working
more than eight hours a day and of
course people say i'm just an [ __ ] to
say something like that but it's i you
know it's the truth working longer gets
more done well so that's kind of uh the
layer one but i'd like to also say that
at least i believe depending on the
person depending on the task
working more and harder will make
you better for the for the next week in
those peak hours
so there's something about
a deep dedication to a thing
that kind of gets deep in you so it's
the the hard work isn't just about the
raw hours of productivity it's the
it's the thing it does to you
in the in the weeks and months after too
you're tempering yourself in some ways
and i think you know it's like jiro
dreams of sushi if you really dedicate
yourself completely to making the sushi
like to really putting in the long hours
day after day after day
um you become a true craftsman of the
thing you're doing
now there's of course discussions about
are you sacrificing a lot of personal
relationships are you sacrificing a lot
of other possible
things you could do with that time but
if you're talking about purely
being
a master or a craftsman of your art that
more hours isn't just about
doing more it's about becoming better at
the thing you're doing yeah and i don't
gain say anybody that wants to work the
minimum amount they've got other
priorities in their life my only
argument that i'm making it's not that
everybody should work hard it's that if
you want to accomplish something working
longer and harder is the path to getting
it accomplished
well let me ask you about this then uh
the the mythical work-life balance
is for an engineer it seems like that's
one of the professions in the
for programmer
where
working hard does lead to greater
productivity in it
but it also raises the question of um
sort of personal relationships and all
that kind of stuff family and
um how are you able to find work-life
balance is there advice you can give
maybe even outside yourself have you
been able to arrive at any wisdom on
this
part in your years of life i do think
that there's a wide range of people
where different people have different
needs it's not a one size fits all and
certainly what works for me i i can tell
enough that
i'm you know i'm different than a
typical average person in the way things
impact me the you know the things that i
want to do my goals are different and
sort of the the levers to impact things
are different where
you know i've literally never felt
burnout and i know there's lots of
brilliant smart people that that do
world-leading work that get burned out
and it's never hit me i'm you know i've
never been at a point where i'm like i'm
i just don't care about this i don't
want to do this anymore but i've always
had the flexibility to work on lots of
interesting things you know i can always
just turn my gaze to something else and
have a great time working on that and so
much of that and so much of the ability
to actually work hard is the ability to
have multiple things to choose from and
to use use your time on the most
appropriate thing like there are there
are time periods where i am it's the
best time for me to read a new research
paper that i need to really be thinking
you know hard about it then there's a
time that maybe i should just scan and
organize my old notes because my you
know i'm just not on top of things then
there's the time that all right let's go
you know bang out a few hundred lines of
code for something
so switching between them
has been real valuable
so you'll always have kind of joy in
your heart for all the things you're
doing and that that is the kind of
work-life balance as a first sort of
step yeah you're always happy i do
happy yeah i mean that's like i a lot of
people would say that often i look like
kind of a grim person you know with just
sitting there with a neutral expression
or even like knitted brows and a frown
on my face as i'm staring at something
that's what happiness looks like for you
yeah
it's it's kind of true or that that's
like okay i'm pushing through this i'm
making progress here i am you know i
know that doesn't work for everyone i
know it doesn't work for most people i
am but what i'm always trying to do in
those cases is i don't want to let
somebody that might be a person like
that be told by someone else that no
don't try it don't even try that out as
an option where
i you know work life
balance versus kind of your life's work
where
there's a small subset of the people
that can be very happy being obsessive
about things and you know obsession can
often get things done that just
practical prudent pedestrian work won't
or at least won't for a very long time
there's legends of uh your nutritional
intake uh
in the early days uh what can you say
about
sort of as a you know
being a programmer as a kind of athlete
so what
what what was uh the nutrition that
fueled so i have never been that great
on i
on really paying attention to it where
i'm good enough that i i don't eat a lot
you know i've never been like a big
heavy guy but
uh it was interesting where one of the
things that i can remember being an
unhappy teenager not having enough money
and like one of the things that bothered
me about not having enough money is i
couldn't buy pizza whenever i wanted to
so i got rich and then i bought a whole
lot of pizza that was defining like
that's what being rich
is a lot of the little things like i
could buy all the pizza and comic books
and video games that uh that i wanted to
and it really didn't take that much but
uh the pizza was one of those things and
it's absolutely true that for a long
time it did software i had a pizza
delivered every single day you know the
delivery guy knew me my name and i
didn't find out until years later that
apparently i was such a good customer
that they just never raised the price on
me and i was using this six-year-old
price for the pizzas that they were
still kind of sending my way every day
so you were doing um eating once a day
or were you uh it would be spread out
you know you have a few pieces of pizza
you have some more later on and i'd
maybe have something at home i it was
one of the nice things that facebook
meta is they do they feed you quite well
you get a different i guess now it's
door dash sorts of things delivered but
uh they take care of making sure that
everybody does get well fed i probably
had better food those six years that i
was working in the meta office there
than i used to before but i've it's
worked out okay for me my health has
always been good i get a pretty good
amount of exercise and
i don't eat to excess and i avoid a lot
of other kind of not so good for you
things so i'm still doing quite well at
my age did you have a
a kind of
i don't know spiritual experience with
food or
coffee or any of that kind of stuff i
mean
you know the programming experience you
know with music and or
or like i listen to brown noise on a
program or like creating an environment
and the things you take into your body
just everything you construct can become
a kind of ritual that empowers the whole
process the program did you have that
relationship with pizza or um it would
really be with diet coke i mean there
still is that sense of you know drop the
can down crack open the can of diet coke
all right now i mean business we're
getting to work here
but still to this day yeah it's diet
coke
yeah probably eight or nine a day
nice
you